every time I need that what is up guys
today's video I'm redoing a flipping
challenge with 10mil GP I'm gonna start
with ten mil do an hour of flipping I'm
gonna be doing any items that I think
are worth doing flipping and the trick
to this video is I'm going to be using
GE tracker so ge tracker is a site that
you can use that shows you which
products are making more money which
products are selling for more profit and
it shows you the margins it shows you
the buy limits it shows you a lot of fun
stuff so I'm be using them they are now
a sponsor of mine so if you guys want to
sign up for GE tracker there is a link
in my description that you guys can go
ahead and sign up through and then be
able to use GE trekker
alright so I'm gonna go ahead and start
the timer now and get flipping so an
item that I see on GE tracker right now
that selling for a good profit is the
occult necklace and the buy limit is
eight of them and they trade quite a bit
so I'm going to go ahead and buy the
occult necklace and then check the
margins for it so it's not even bitin
for that so it's probably someone for a
while right now alright so
I have the price that it sells for and
then the price to buy it for okay so
that's about 12 K margin so I'll buy
these for 495 K or whoops for 95 K and
I'll go ahead and buy five of them
because the buy limits eight and I only
have ten mil to spend so 495 okay sweet
and I will look for another item so the
dark bo is going for a good price right
now so we'll check dark Bo check the
margin on these okay so it's going for
about 10 K so buy these for about let's
try 428 500 and we will buy we'll go
ahead and buy five of those see what the
buy limit is on that eight of them okay
okay so they're already buying so I'm
gonna go ahead and flip this right away
so I'm just held for 430 just under four
39k what another one is buying okay so
those are coming through pretty quick so
I might have bought them for a little
bit too much money but that's okay what
was I selling them for let's check for
39 just under 439 439 kay just under
that okay and let's go ahead and find
some other items or actually I saw an
item that was flipping well oh I already
sold these so woops I shoulda sold both
of them okay so 439 k okay we'll sell
that and an other item that I saw was
flipping well right now is the Sears
ring we'll go ahead and check the margin
on these see those dark wasn't already
selling so that's already a 10k profit
so let's check these see earnings L okay
so this is gonna be a big one if I get
these so we'll buy five of these already
selling these dark bows
all right so these cold necklaces are
coming in slow so I will go ahead and
check for some more items another item
that normally does well is this tis
arquette ohm which is the abbey mall so
we'll go ahead and check that okay one
of the equal necklaces came in oh and
all undermine no other surging scam and
I thought they all came in all right so
that's a 4k margin we'll check how many
can we buy a while by limiting its
seventy on these geez
we'll just go ahead and buy five of them
to be safe 187 Kay that's about a 3k
margin so these are cool necklaces are
coming in let's check what the margins
were on these so we can sum for 506 K
okay so we'll kind of let everything sit
we'll put this one in real quick for 39
K and these are called necklaces okay
everything is already selling so I will
be back when I do a little bit more
flips and move these around
alright so things are actually going
crazy right now I've already bought and
sold a bunch of things and I'm not sure
how long it's been since the last time
you guys I've seen me but it's been
maybe like 30 seconds and like
everything's going crazy right now we'll
just go ahead and collect everything
some of the Hobby models are coming in
some of these ear rings are selling and
they're selling for a 20k profit that is
insane I'll check the buy limit on these
again and see what they are selling for
let me go ahead and put these in I'm
going to abort these ones too and then
sell them all together let's check what
I'm supposed to sell it for so I sell it
for for just under 4 39k okay or 39k
just under that and then okay there's
all the sears rings sweet already sold
one of them so that was already a 20k
profit that is ridiculous for 98k just
under 4 98k was that right 498 came that
comes a little too high you have 398 K
okay sweet
three 98k three 98k just under there all
right and then I'll go ahead and sell
these malls too and I'll be back all
right it's probably been about another
minute and a lot of things are selling
so I sold all those cult necklaces that
was pretty good margins I'm not sure
what it was but looking at GE tracker it
says these redwood redwood logs are
selling for a good profit and I'm on the
high-volume item so this is just items
that sell a bunch per hour so I'm gonna
go ahead and check the margins on the
redwood logs I mean if there's over 4G P
between these I'll do it because that's
okay that's insane that's a lot so how
many can we buy what's the max on this
so 12,000 so we'll buy about 10,000 of
them because we want to be able to sell
them and they're selling for that but I
have a feeling that they won't sell for
that so I'm gonna go ahead and up the
price we actually are still selling some
items these dark boughs are starting to
sell what are some other items on here
so it says limp or limp
worked roots yeah sorry about that I
don't want to say it so it says those
are doing well right now - it says a lot
of them are selling and the GP margin is
pretty high so we'll go ahead and check
that it's about three GP not really
worth it so I'm gonna go ahead and keep
checking those items and I'll be back
from the find anyone so I went ahead and
check the margins on diamond bolts II
because normally these have really good
margins and the GE limit is 11,000 and
they sell a lot so I'm gonna see how
many I can buy how much money do I have
we'll buy about we'll try to you know
we'll do a 5k of them because I don't
wanna buy too many and it seems like
someone just checked the margin on these
so I think I'm gonna get undercut on
these because they're realizing that
others are selling so I'm gonna have to
recheck those in a sec and right now
some of the dark boughs I have sold
actually those already sold and then
these seedlings are taking a little bit
of time so and so are these all be malls
so I'll give it a little bit more time
and then I might switch the margins next
time I see you guys a lot of these
diamond bolts these are coming in
they're kind of slowing down I went
ahead and redid the price on these
big malls I might redo the price on
these in a second because those were
raising margins anyways but another item
that it says is these extended anti
fires I'm kind of curious to see what
these are selling for was it the forest
yeah okay so let's just see if the
margins are good right now in these
because a lot of them sell yeah so those
are good margins so we'll go ahead
what's the buy limit on these mm so
we'll just buy a thousand five hundred
well let those say it and so these album
odds are starting to sell now that I
change the price these diamond bolts are
still coming in I'm going to change some
of these prices and I'll be back so it's
in another item that was doing well was
the Tama fire so I went ahead and
checked the margins on these and it
seems like it has pretty good margin the
buy limit on these are 15 so I'll go
ahead and buy just enough and so I'll
collect all the items so all of my I'll
be mall sold so that's good I switched
up the Sears prices and I'm gonna wait
for all this stuff to come in so I'll be
back all right I've sold a few items and
now all these have bought so I'm gonna
sell them for 420 because I bought them
for 16 so once I sell these then I'll
start having some more money to spend
these aren't buying right now I had to
move these down because they haven't
been selling which sucks is they were
like a 20 something k margin I think but
anyways I'm gonna have to probably get
rid of these tomes of fires they're not
buying I might have to change the
margins a little bit these are coming in
slowly if they don't sort of coming in
faster I'll have to change the price on
that so I'll be back alright I found a
new item I just canceled at the tomah
fire scooter is taking too long so I
found the Augie capes so I'm gonna buy
these for 451 K probably just under
there and the buy limits like 70 of
these so I'm just gonna buy 10 of them
and then if I can manage to get that
then that's gonna be almost a 20k flip
for things so that'll be some good money
right there um I still have about a mil
to spend so I might look at some other
items and then come back so thankfully
some of these are starting to sell to
these IB capes are sold so I'm gonna go
ahead and try to flip those real quick
so 467 k so that's almost a 20k margin
467 k go just underneath so that'll be
some good margins these still are
selling I checked the margin and that is
the lowest price these aren't selling so
that kind of sucks so
go ahead and collect some money and then
I'll be back all right so I saw that
these cannonballs are flipping well so
I'm gonna buy about I'm all buy six gave
them so those are flipping well and then
I'll let those sit and these obsidian
kids have already sold four and I have
another one so that's about a 17k margin
and these are slowly coming in so
looking good all right these capes are
selling so quick and these cannonballs
actually bought way too quick so I
bought them for too much money oh well
hopefully I'll be able to flip them for
167 and make some good margins and then
I'll just go ahead and put these in
cause I actually stopped selling these
things you're selling for 518 so I'll
just put them in for 515 and just just
home for a little bit of extra money Wow
I already sold those those were a super
quick flip on these so I just made like
30k on that so I'll probably look for
some more items like that and see if I
can get lucky again so I'm gonna go
ahead and flip coal now and I think the
buy limits like 12 K so let me just
check 13k it's all by 10 K of them and
then I'll sell them and then these all
be capes are just selling like crazy man
like this is really good flip so I got
really lucky so I'm already buying these
so I probably put them in for too much
money but hopefully it just goes real
quick and then I can just flip him real
quick all right so I did a new item I
did wizard boots and they're coming in
really well everything's selling really
well so I'm gonna flip these wizard
boots it'll be about a 10k profit so
I'll be back when I'm a stuff still
selling so I'm gonna let stuff sit a
little bit more I'm about halfway
through it's been 31 minutes so I'll be
down in about 30 minutes so I'll just
keep doing this and see what happens I
actually just found a crazy margin on
holy sandals using G trekker so I can
buy about six of them I'll probably only
buy for them because there are a lot of
money and I don't want to lose too much
and a lot of items are still coming in I
just got more Robbie capes sweet so I'll
go ahead and try to buy these if I can
get this that's like 50 K margin that's
insane all right all the coals sold so I
can sell that for let's just check so
one sixty one and we'll go ahead and
sell it for that and then I'll come back
on some other items have sold actually
decided to just invest back in these op
capes because I think the by limits
seventy of them and they're just selling
like crazy
so I'm going to keep doing that and I'm
just gonna let everything sit for
probably like ten minutes and then come
back and just see though all the coals
sold and I'm already selling out of Cape
so it took
like 30 seconds so the coal I made
almost how much is that I made 40k I
mean that was so easy I'm just gonna
keep looking at items and I'll be back
again so we have about 17 minutes left
getting down to crunch time I'm gonna
buy about 5k of these and hopefully sell
them for some good easy profit these
wizard boots finally sold I move my
Sears rings down a lot because I'm
scared they're not gonna sell in time so
I'm making about a 1k profit on these
not great but not terrible I'll be capes
are still coming in and wizard boots
just sold so hopefully we can buy some
more these sharks are coming in so we'll
see how that goes and I'll be back again
literally within like 20 seconds these
sharks already sold so I can sell them
for 702 so I'll assume for 702 and we'll
see how that goes
I mean that's gonna be quick like 40k
profit and I think the buy limit on
these is 10 K so I could even buy about
4 K more of them so I'll be back alright
it is 51 minutes after these sharks so
I'm gonna go ahead and cancel these
because I am just under an hour and I
know if I start investing a little bit
more money I'm gonna end up losing a
bunch of money because they're not gonna
sell in time so these sharks are selling
so I'm just gonna go ahead and board
these offers and once these sharks sell
I will go ahead and show you guys the
profit I made in just under an out I'll
write everything is done and it took 52
minutes so I'm gonna go ahead and pause
that and we'll see how much money I made
in one hour flipping everything with GE
tracker alright so I made 326 K almost
327 k so that's how much I made it in
how are using GE tracker again guys if
you want to use this awesome feature B
that shows you all the prices and all
the margins and how much they're selling
for and which items are most profitable
at the moment go ahead and click that
link in my description and go ahead and
sign up alright guys thank you so much
for watching if you want to see more
videos like this go ahead and give this
video a like so I know you guys like
these flippin videos if you have any
suggestions in the comments for any kind
of videos or if you just want to talk to
me in game go ahead and leave a comment
in the comment section and as always
guys please subscribe to my channel if
you're new to the channel and thanks
guys for watching stay tuned for my next
video